[Music]
[Applause]
yeah you're calling come on
yeah no mana oh man Tina we submitted by
do you want that with boba yes Oh extra
sometimes depends on what place I'm
getting in there just only have the
pudding it's okay
I prefer if you're having me pick boba
or pudding what about grass jelly no
Lafayette grass Victor Rodya black tea
and grass jelly maybe a dope rapper's
name grass jelly anyway
the hiring manager for a delivery
company was fired after mocking even a
nice man for his English skills to leave
in about this [ __ ] up but it's kind of
funny kind of funny
vitaminas [ __ ] up bad guy I had my
mind dad did you hear that huh yeah what
he just Vietnamese is [ __ ] up what the
accent oh yeah so we're trying to get a
loan right Baker is right yeah
we're going there and she hasn't [ __ ]
stereotypical accent huh
yeah and so she was telling me that uh
one of for one of the barbell companies
we didn't get approved yeah so it's kind
of like sad news but when you're saying
it with the Vietnamese like I'm sorry
but you don't get it but another option
to get the money and I'm like can you be
[ __ ] serious like just like you're
pissing me off right now [ __ ] English
you know what the process
I can imagine her she's like you don't
get money oh sorry you don't get the
money sir
unfortunately your business don't make
enough profit come on [ __ ] just
tell me some all [ __ ] you guys have
mocked the vietnamese language so much
anytime you hear you think is a [ __ ]
joke I'm sorry but yo daddy died let's
do this right now
you [ __ ] Vietnamese dr. Beach this
ain't a JK video normal with you wanting
for mujer you're gonna die on me across
that with a [ __ ] wig on sorry
my poor people [ __ ] we're never taken
seriously [ __ ] oh you're taking
seriously yeah there's like I'll get
Jennifer to help me Alma yeah please get
Jennifer she's English ambassador here
because the whole night I was talking
about it when I was driving home you're
giving me all kinds of bad news no
[ __ ] manager [ __ ] a firefighter or a
doctor giving you bet you only have
three months to live I'm sorry I
actually want news that way don't you
guys know if you ever need to like
really like if you need to break really
bad news to Bart just do it with a
Vietnamese person and it'll be okay
I'm sorry Billy I want all my news that
way I'll do it for you you're getting
all the worst [ __ ]
Isis is back that in a good day
[Laughter]
this is the worst article to do this one
I'm so sorry sir no but I happened to be
in real life so I could completely
relate you really need to the villain
here that's what you're saying don't
have a Vietnamese Baker yeah so the
gurney was Emily she tweeted this out so
it's a screenshot of an email and then
her caption says non-english speakers
really have it hard because my dad just
got rejected from his job offer and the
email literally stated let me tell you
now if you know speak English I will
send you home oh that is stupid
she writes what the [ __ ] plus all of
Bruce's emails were also very
unprofessional and passive-aggressive
because the the father is um email but
you can tell he doesn't speak English
his first language yeah the top one it
says so what if they're just writing in
a way he understands oh my god I see
that so many times when for some reason
when someone is speaking to like someone
that doesn't speak English like an Asian
person right they always have to talk to
them like they're [ __ ] mentally to
say yeah dude that I'm like how the [ __ ]
do you start having an Asian accent and
I'm all like dude you're a 60 year old
white man how did you turn into a
Vietnamese lady you know it is a little
contagious cuz like when will travel
Casey does that yeah he'll do that to
people that don't understand English
like obviously because we're in a
different country right and when we're
trying to communicate in English and
he's like but you know like over there
and I'm like just talk normally like
he's I get why though but you don't have
to talk of why but does he do that like
in Italy like does he start becoming
more Italian life
No speak to them like they're dumb and
I'm like yeah a lot of people do that
though I know he's trying to speak
slower and like you know so they could
understand the English but then when he
speaks that way I'm like that comes off
a little offense and like just chocolate
I think it's like how you say it too
because I've seen like why people do
that to Mexican people mm-hmm
you know escuela you know like they just
sound so [ __ ] douchey if it comes off
condescending it's [ __ ] exactly where
they take out the filler word cuz they
just need the main one exactly like I'm
hungry or like hungry food like I get it
it's like it's that and it's also for
some reason when you don't speak English
people to hear deaf you know like you
don't need to be loud that's [ __ ]
hilarious what [ __ ] my friend gob oh
he speaks Spanish he's like African dude
this will went to a Pollo Loco start
speaking Spanish to the lady she was
like I don't speak Spanish she was
latina yeah that's so cute he's trying
so hard to like show it off yeah this
was like right before he went to Ecuador
for a couple years and I just looked at
him I said please don't do it bro this
is a change I don't speak Spanish he
should have been like I don't speak
English
save it yeah so the next tweet here
she's Emily writes I understand that the
job requires English but his emails
could have been handled way more
professionally this email was Broce
unnecessary and degrading you know why
it's one of those guys that are like if
they could get away with being a
[ __ ]
they will yeah and they probably think
that since this guy doesn't know English
you could say whatever the [ __ ] he wants
and no one nothing's gonna happen to him
the shitty thing about this this this
guy his position in the company is HR HR
work the dumbest [ __ ] ever and he's in
marketing to HR and marketing in this
case what the [ __ ] well that's already a
shitty he branded himself really well
what company
it's called - delivery - deliveries is
that like a but he's just asking to be a
delivery guy well I'm not sure exactly
what position he's applying for but it's
for that company so yeah I'm assuming if
it's a delivery person you need like
perfect English know what you do you
pick up and then you know what a big
deal huh I don't I don't get why well we
don't know what he's applying for yeah
so then she oh I'm terribly - CEO okay
job that's what I broke my [ __ ] heart
yes oh she also tweeted this it says my
dad came up to me and asked in Chinese
what was that word you mentioned to me
earlier
oh he's Chinese both that's why they
didn't hire me cuz I'm bad at it and
then he wrote it down in the paper and
it's his grammar so grammar is the
reason why it sucks she wrote in the
caption of this photo update my dad
isn't that hurt he just doesn't fully
understand the concept of someone not
hiring him for his lack of English I'm
just trying to teach English by what the
hell he has more experience when he has
more experience than most people
well what experience does he have well
he was working in a truck delivery
service or company for many many many
years but then he ended up losing that
job because he couldn't get a license in
time so that's right now for the last
two years he's been applying everywhere
wait wait he did truck driving for many
years and then they told him outta
nowhere get a license no apparently he
couldn't get it in time it was like 13
years and he got laid off no then the
article will be wrote that he needed a
license and then he was in a he couldn't
obtain that license within a certain
amount of time for some reason so then
that's why they were some jobs are like
that where they let you on the job first
if you have experience but you need to
get the license within three months or
six months I think he was working for
like 13 yeah it's like it makes sense if
you're like well we require we require
mom you to understand English like you
you need to be able to communicate with
the customers or whatever that's fine
but if you not speaking English you
cannot come here
that's not
[ __ ] a lot of people were replying to
the girl saying you know that's illegal
like you can't discriminate you can't
discriminate like that like that
straight up wait they can't discriminate
based on you not knowing English pretty
much the way he handled it he handled
that yeah that was clearly fun enough
unprofessionally there's a lawyer that
tweeted back said hey so I'm part of
this law firm blah blah blah we're gonna
be in contact with that company and then
she oh [ __ ] yeah oh I love it because
you could totally tell that this person
thought they can be a [ __ ] dick face
they probably showed his friends inside
yeah I mean look at this [ __ ] oh you
know so then luckily there's a happy
ending in this story so she tweets this
out she says best update he got fired
y'all I love everyone who shared this
like this read this article etc we no
longer have to deal with this trash and
then it's just the email of the company
just saying very generic things like you
know he was not it doesn't reflect our
company I would love to see that guy do
like an uncle sound vlog where the who
did their time did a truck driver back I
want to get the other guys interview I
want I want to see how [ __ ] douchey
that guy is cuz his name is Bruce yeah I
can't get like a douche vibe from him I
already kind of know what he looks like
here like no Nick Peterson is the last
name huh well it's no Nick I promise you
that what if he actually speaks like
that and he's all like why why why I
know higher normal cuz I know yeah I
know understand enough he don't speak
English neither do I it's a confusing
man if you don't know I don't know we
won't know
[Music]